[Music]
hey
i haven't seen you in your uniform for a
while yeah that was uh
on purpose hmm kind of turns me on
there he is general patton and a neon
vest
wow they say a half a million people
watch
the boston marathon here in new england
hey you behaving yourself
we've got to decide who's running this
and we have to decide quickly
it's terrorism we'll take it
and let's get an evidence for it started
right over there
clock is ticking the world is watching
the suspect seen on the surveillance
cameras
two bombers we gotta find these guys
before they do this to someone else
we can't have our citizens on the
streets with all these threats
every inch of this city is getting
searched we're shutting it down
[Music]
a taxi picked up a guy matching white
house description could be
on his way to new york are there more
bombs
are there more bombs i want a lawyer no
no i have rights
you ain't got [ __ ] sweetheart
what i saw today good versus evil
love versus hate
there's only one weapon you have to
fight back with
it's love
we wrap our arms around each other
i don't think there's any way that they
can ever win
i know what you're thinking how the heck
does a 52 year old
over the hill milkshake machine salesman
build a fast food empire with 1600
restaurants
and an annual revenue of 700 million
dollars
one word persistence
prince castle sales ray how's it going
down there
good swell a lot of interest we got an
order
six mixers twenty one in particular
mcdonald's
mcdonald's there for a little tour
we wanted something different and that's
when my brother here comes up with one
of his brilliant ideas
orders ready in 30 seconds not 30
minutes unique
original there's nothing like this it's
revolutionary that's exactly what it's
revolutionary what is that
the golden arches it's a way to make the
place stand out huh
there should be mcdonald's everywhere
franchise the damn thing what's the
first step
just leave that to me
that
did you mortgage our home we could lose
everything
good things come to those who ate
business is war it's doggy dog i could
be growing this thing at twice the pace
i don't know what to say say you'll
renegotiate i can't
gander one what you ought to be doing is
owning the land
upon which that burger is cooked you're
not in the burger business you're in the
real estate business
there's a wolf in the hen house we let
him in
that's enough going to be enough for you
honestly
business is war it's doggy dog
rat eat rat to succeed to win
opportunity sky's the limit you have a
contract this is not your company ray
are you sure about that
i work this blaze near big timber
montana
and the blink of knobs fire everywhere
and then charging out of these flames
comes this bear on fire
it was the most beautiful and terrible
thing i've ever seen
i heard you guys had some slots
available
what are you doing here i just had a
daughter
and i just really want to give her what
i never had
if you give me a chance i won't let you
down
you know the difference between type 2
crew and hot shots
yes their hot shots are on the front
line and they get to engage the fire
directly
you guys are type 2 so why don't you do
what you do best
stay in the back and uh mop up our [ __ ]
you want to talk about it anyone do your
telling or anything
[Music]
we've been training for over four years
got all our hours all our qualifications
sooner or later fire's gonna come
knocking in our hometown but until we're
certified
my crew won't even be able to set foot
on the line
doing something that's never been done
before takes time
it's not easy sharing your man with a
fire i want y'all to breathe in this
beautiful vista
because once you're hot shots you're
never going to be able to look out into
the wild
see that pure beauty again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the fire gets past our line it goes to
our town okay
we're working our way around there no
matter what you hear
[Music]
no matter what's going on we can't go
back up there stand together
look out for each other because you're a
family
[Music]
no one could be prouder of his boys than
i am of you guys
[Music]
whoa
the closer you are to death the more
alive you feel
you're james aren't you yes
who's that it's nikki lowder he's just
been signed by ferrari
nobody look at the way he's driving like
an old man
right now with zero incentive why would
i drive fast
this is an incredible battle between
these two great drivers
next time i'll have you no chance you're
just a party guy that's why everybody
likes you
yes i know i'm terrible no you're not
terrible you're just who you are at this
point in your life
don't be a champion it takes more than
just being quick you have to really
believe it
i've been waiting for this my whole life
i can beat this guy trust me he's
consistent
dependable he put his life
[Music]
louder trapped in a searing inferno with
800 plus degrees
[Music]
talk to me james don't go to men who are
willing to kill themselves driving in
circles looking for normality
and what did your wife say when she saw
your face she said you don't need the
face to dress
you just need the right foot i feel
responsible for what happened
watching you win those races while i was
fighting for my life
you were equally responsible for getting
me back in the car
42 days after his near fatal accident
nikki louder will race here today
more powerful in the fear of death
[Music]
is the will to win
there's not much time you got to be
miles away from here
where is she follow that noah stop
if they're no stars just follow the
river
listen for them
fear is your enemy whoa
easy now i'm gonna be freaked down
i don't know if you know how
extraordinary this is but you have made
it 100 miles to freedom
all by yourself would you like to pick a
new name
to mark your freedom hair tummy
[Music]
you are welcome here anytime if i'm free
my family should be too
i made up my mind i'm going back
you're confident composed when trouble
comes
you'll be ready papers it says here
you're five and a half feet tall
you ain't more than five feet
muscle in my house that day
why you back here it ain't safe
i come to get you bring all of you to
freedom
do you know what would happen if you got
caught
you got lucky harriet
i made a disc on my own so don't you
tell me what i can do
[Music]
harriet welcome to the underground
railroad
everybody everywhere is looking for you
god don't mean people to own people
find this thief and burn her at the
stake
i will give every last drop of blood in
my face
until this monster called slavery is
dead
ready
[Applause]
i'm watching that give me the remote no
you've been bit off
zack what bloody hell do you think
you're doing
you really want to choke her out in a
lot of fingers now pull it tight
oh yeah now she's in trouble oh wait i
know you
you're from that weird family aren't you
we're not weird we don't like wrestling
how do you know if you've ever been
i've never had rectal bleeding before
but i'm pretty sure i'm not a fan of
that
how about i shove her head up your ass
then we can find out
[Music]
hello my name is hutch morgan i'm
calling from wwe
i'd like both of you to come try out for
us
it's all fake anyways
sorry about that it's a rock we're huge
fans thank you so much what advice would
you give us we want to be the next you
what are your names again
mining it doesn't matter what your names
are you walk around here interrupting to
rock you like you haven't seen the sun
in 20 years
you like you just stepped out of oliver
twist please sir may i have some more
advice
you want some advice here's a rocket by
shut your mouth thanks duane
got it good morning wrestling nerds well
this is where we see whether or not you
get to go on the wwe
this is our shot hello why do you want
to wrestle i'm the toughest bastard in
any room
probably shouldn't swear i wonder if
ladies present sorry miss
sorry about that if i call your name
that means you'll be coming with me to
florida
paige thank you all very much
you have to take my brother no one
deserves this more than zach i wish you
the best son but this is the end of the
line for you
do you know what it's like to want one
thing in life and then your own sister
takes it away from you
it was my dream too i have no idea who
i'm supposed to be out there
you're not just doing this view you're
doing it for the family
paige i myself have come from a
wrestling family too i know exactly what
it means to you
but don't worry about being the next man
be the first you
what it's dwayne johnson how are you
prove it
is cooking yeah and i'm vin diesel mate
i'm sorry
[Music]
everything okay i don't like the look of
that
they're coming in fast
this is a mask alabama we are an unarmed
freighter we
have two skiffs approaching with armed
intruders potential piracy situations
copy alabama you should alert your crew
and get your fire hoses ready
yeah is that it chances are it's just
fishermen
they're not here to fish
shots take the hoses this is not a drill
the real world situation
listen up we have been boarded by armed
pirates
if they find you remember you know the
ship
they don't stick together
it will be all right
one minute i will kill all your friends
everything's gonna be okay look at me
sure
look at me i'm the captain now
captain phillips can you hear me captain
phillips can you hear me
come on get up morning run
stephen are you aware that you're
voluntarily marked upon a phd in physics
hello hello science arts
i'm a cosmologist what's that i study
the marriage of space and time
the perfect couple
one never knows from where the next
great leap forward is going to come
or from home
what if i reverse time to see what
happened at the beginning of time itself
pulling back the clock lying back the
clock
keep going i don't know how
yet keep winding
where's here
called motor neuron disease life
expectancy is
two years i want us to be together for
as long as we've got
it'll affect everything you don't
realize what lies ahead
this is going to be a very heavy defeat
but i love him and he loves me
we're going to fight this illness
together
good luck hi
are you okay so
this black hole at the beginning of time
brilliant brilliant steam well done
dot he has pneumonia
the only way he will survive would be to
give him a track here to me he will
never speak again
yes he will my name is stephen hawking
it's american is that a problem
it has been a great joy to watch this
man defy
every expectation both scientific
and personal
there should be no boundaries to human
endeavor
however bad life may seem well there is
life
there is hope thank you
sorry did you say something
i said thank you
what we know is that saddam has this
material you don't know that i mean he
just keeps repeating the lie
just because you're the prime minister
it doesn't mean you get to make up your
own facts
someone in this building has betrayed
their country
if you are found to have withheld
information you will be charged
with a breach of the official secrets
act
catherine who do you think reminds us
[Music]
who brought you this friend be careful
this is real you can go to jokes for
having in your possession you're a spy
you work for the british government no
i work for the british people i do not
collect information so that the
government
can lie to the british people
intelligence may be being manipulated to
take this country to war
this paper needs to stop taking tony
blair at face value
[Music]
you had nothing to gain and everything
to lose this could result in a prisoner
sentence
do you want to risk it all this war
is historically unpopular it's
everywhere
every country biggest demonstration in
human history
if we do not go public we would be
conceding that no one can ever tell the
people when their government
is lying
[Music]
what he did he was extraordinary
the war is illegal
the public is entitled to know why
my motive was to stop a war and save
lives i have to tell the truth
you